hi I'm Ryan Wright tonight we're gonna
watch a video I can't do this the whole
[ __ ] video we're gonna watch a video
today everyone's raving about this I
didn't get a chance to tune in for it
Cameron monoghan monahon as Jerome aka
the Joker in Gotham now this is a huge
[ __ ] deal
this is the next performance for
watching after Heath Ledger's Joker I
know Jared Leto's playing the Joker and
Suicide Squad but this is technically
the first performance we've gotten of
the Joker a sense Heath Ledger so the
fact that everyone saying he's doing a
great job is pretty [ __ ] awesome
because that's a lot of pressure I'm
sure this guy have to deal with and I'm
sure that everyone on the show sort of
felt a pressure for it so I'm excited to
see what this is about
you know mr. Cicero from the show yes
that hello mr. Cicero good evening drew
you know why you're here did you find
out what killed my mother you killed
your mother Jerome
you killed her up on that hill and mr.
Cicero lets you clean up in his trailer
he told you to scratch the cygnus stuff
and a hatchet and right off the bridge
that's absurd and in the fence of what
is the truth what I don't know is why
this man was so much to help you I think
he's your father don't know what you're
talking about
my father was a sea captain
am I wrong mr. Cicero yes it was a sea
captain his name is Sven Coast and he
died at sea what was the name of his
ship he worked on the live different
ships when he went down she never said
we can do a blood test to prove on right
thanks only half an hour to get a
foolproof result it's never right dr.
target yes say herself anew activate
needles I'm sorry drew we rejected it
out he's right I am your father could
not I would you say that you must have
suspected the truth you're not my father
my mother
we never mother was a cruel woman since
often unkind to me but she did once love
me in her way and she loved you very
much
that's why she gave you a better father
my mother is a cold-hearted [ __ ] who
never loved anyone and she ever touched
a pathetic Oh creep like you all these
years do you think I was kind to you
because I'm such a good man
if I wasn't your father would I helped
you as I have after what you did I found
her oh I'll be damned
that's very funny
Shh looks like the [ __ ] got me with it
finger in the end why did you kill your
mother true oh you know how mothers are
she just kept pushing and I'm like my
mom be a [ __ ] be a drunken [ __ ] even
but don't be a nagging drunken [ __ ] you
know don't come yell at me to do the
dishes if you've been dating a flowers
I got two Jack Nicholson offered us an
origin story of the Joker
Heath Ledger's you don't really get an
origin tale you're seeing the Joker here
when he was a young dude it is an
interesting type of origin tale they're
providing for us and this guy is making
it his own it's a really three
dimensional performance I'm assuming
it's a split personality he has
everything about him was really good you
know like before he made his
transformation into his other
personality as the Joker
he was very believable as this guy who
just feels like his mother has been lost
and it feels like a loan and about you
basically we're getting the Joker from a
real traumatic experience he's someone
who has become who he is because of some
heavy trauma and while that's safe to
assume with any performance of the Joker
I feel like this time around we're
really getting to examine the psychology
behind his mind which is something that
I think a lot of people haven't been
brave enough to really go into the
Joker's been good at being more
mysterious and not and not really
knowing what his background is has
really helped and making his character
that much bigger and that much better
but I feel like their approach here to
really exploring you know the psychology
behind him and what's made him like go
psychotic is you actually kind of
sympathize for the guy at the same time
you know like he's a guy who just dissed
Ramat eyes then you feel bad for him and
I know you like killed his mom which is
so not cool but even still like I
somehow actually really care about this
diva game he's a young guy and it's a
split personality and his transformation
as the Joker was perfect
he didn't overdo it he didn't go
full-out with like a new voice and whole
body language like it changed yeah like
the voice did change a little bit
mannerisms did change but he just kept
it you know in a real way like he did it
he just knew the right levels of what to
hit and that laughs was great too it was
like a perfect Joker laughs
because it wasn't like the lap that
we've heard from like Mark Hamill that
we've heard from Jack Nicholson Heath
Ledger it was reminiscent of that but it
also had its own flair to it
ya know that was a great performance I
should probably get because I saw the
first two episodes and I kind of lost
interest but I think I'm gonna start
continuing this show now anyway guys
thanks for telling me that video is out
that was great if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects where we keep it real I'm stupid
the stupid Chris Fowler ba buff Chris
fire Bob Chris Fowler bah hey what's up
man just discover your channel a while
black and I'm glad you died did you seem
like a funny dude you're a funny dude
now you keep the jokes coming Chris you
and your big [ __ ] I would love a shout
out good you should what huh what are
you mad that I said he has a big [ __ ]
are you sure yeah okay good Christy I'm
a medium-sized penis that okay I'm not
coming on to him I'm just complimenting
his penis don't care I'm complimenting
Chris flower balls penis that's what he
calls his penis the Fowler ball
it stands for gigantic caillou [ __ ] it's
a god it's a caillou monster in the
shape of a penis Chris Fowler about I
think you've earned yourself a shout-out